don't talk
excuse me
right morning everybody uh welcome to
the growth screw to me
uh committee final one of this this year
um damon
do do we make some sort of announcements
at this point in the moment normally
do you do it yeah just in four members
that we are being
um streaming live to youtube and this
meeting is being recorded for the
purposes
right thank you for that uh we've had a
couple of apologies
um councillor cornwall and
councillor whitehead wasn't it um do we
have any any declarations of interest
not at all that's good that's very good
um and the minutes of the last meeting
any issues
anything anybody like to bring up from
the
the the minutes of the last meeting
good that's the right to it uh
well in that case then i'd like to
welcome uh
collapse uh to the meeting this morning
um and he's gonna give us a bit of a
presentation aren't you calm
yeah yeah sorry thank you are you happy
for me to start
a view to start great thank you i'm just
going to share my screen
okay they're able to see that
yes i can say okay so um
as you're aware i'm here to talk a
little bit about the one public estate
today
okay
okay so so far we've um secured 215
215 000 pounds of external funding
secured towards um
one public state and we've carried out
um
two studies so far locality reviews on
the avenue
and another one on clay cross and then
currently we're carrying out
um one across eckington and kilomarch
so one public state has three core
objectives and that's the creation of
economic growth in the form of new jobs
and homes delivery of better integrated
and customer focused services
and the generation of efficiencies
through capital receipts and reduction
in running costs
so what that looks like in practice is
quite often
and public services are delivered via
a number of buildings that are spread
across a town or a locality
and there's around how can that be more
efficiently used so quite often it's
about co-location
and then what that means is that the
spare land or building that
that was previous previously occupied is
able to be
disposed of creating a capital receipt
and then that can be brought forward for
our commercial space or housing
depending on which is most appropriate
and then the the um the running costs of
that new building is shared across
others generally it's a newer building
as well so it's a bit more efficient in
terms of energy usage and also
um in running costs in terms of
liability for the maintenance
so we as i say we carried out a locality
review on the avenue
so what you'll see here if you can see
my cursor is that
red part there that's the bit where
um it's partly owned by the homes
england and then
also this pink bit that's owned by
ourselves
uh northeast district council so it's
around how do we integrate those two
pieces
into a considered development because we
know that this area here can be brought
forward
by the access that's already in and it's
how do we make sure that
when we develop our part of the the site
which would have an access at the bottom
that it's almost like it flows from one
um development into the others so it's a
considered development which is
obviously a lot more efficient because
if you do all the sewers and the road
connections and all the same at the same
time
you know they all sort of fit in
perfectly and it will flow right
and then the housing development also
flows one into others so
it's almost you wouldn't realize that
it's owned by two different
organizations so that master plan work
has been carried out and that's what
we've
um secured and this is what
we're working towards bringing forward
so it's as you can see a housing
development
with a green card over there and then
there's some commercial space a bit
lower down there
um as you as mentioned there we've
completed
one public state for click cross
and one of the main ticket items in that
was a community hub
so there's two scenarios considered for
that community open that
some of the suggestions were to
co-locate the library education
service health services youth focus
services level provision
and the cafe so that was one of the
suggestions from the
one public safety for clay cross as part
of that and so this is the first snow
that
they suggested a town center hub keeping
the current building as you can see and
then having an extension
on the side proposed extension where as
i say it's
got the list of different things that it
was proposing that could be brought
forward as part of that development
and so that was maintaining the existing
building
and then the next one was a refurb i'm
sorry i'd not refurb a brand new
development as you can see just there
with the artist's impression of what it
could look like um
in that area what i also suggested
and what one of the opi projects that
we've been able to progress
is the bridge street depot so that depot
um was let out to some businesses but it
was it was
was wasn't quite well it wasn't really
fit for purpose in terms of
the energy supply the water supply
wasn't to all the units because it was
an old depo they're being converted into
um usable space for commercial but it
wasn't really
um appropriate and um it was suggested
in the op
work that we would clear that and bring
forward and some
suitable commercial space in there and
we're looking to develop um low carb in
um
commercial space which is great so all
the tenants have been successfully
relocated
uh demolition is complete and the plan
application for low carbon commercial
spare
space march 2021 and i've got a meeting
next week to discuss what that's going
to look like
so that's really exciting that's that's
an example of what's actually happened
and and
was pushed um ideally firstly through
the
one public estate and then it came
through the
clay crossed um town fund
so as you were we've secured 24 or
hopefully you're aware we've secured
24.1 million
of funding towards clay cross and that
was through the town investment plan
but the basis for all of that work
started in the one public estate work
that was the foundation that the town
investment plan was built on so a lot of
projects identified within
um the op work have been taken forward
through the
investment plan and now we've uh working
towards
drawing down that 24.1 million and
developing the business cases for the
different projects identified
again all other routes in one public
estate so it just showed that um
it does bring forward and redevelop
so that's the ones that we we've had so
far completed and then moving on to
and the ones that we're in the middle of
working on now
so we've got um eckington so we're
looking at um development
opportunities there and service
precision provision across the town
primarily looking at the town center at
castle hill the ambulance site
and some bungalows again in grand castle
hill real close
uh school street site and pipe yard
lanes play field so that's kind of been
the main focus of the one public state
work
picking up all the key areas uh dave i
think
um hurry neck in turn especially around
the town centre and then
the provision of this sort of space here
and whether it can be more efficiently
used
um so yeah in eckington so the work has
been taken so far is we've got per
consulting
and they've been working on that
throughout them the the lockdown which
has been quite challenging for
however they've managed to do the
background baseline suite that's
completed
stakeholder discussions have been held
options for project area is presented to
the parish council
and the point we're at now is that we're
working on the final option being
finalized and then the final report
is due sort of this month into next we
pushed it into
after may well in may later on in may
because of the county council
elections the county council are
obviously a partner within this
so when they're kind of stopped at the
minute in terms of the pre-election
period of what they can and can't do so
we've pushed that final report to be
signed off
and post the county council elections
okay so moving on to kilowatch which is
one of the other principal towns
in the district that we're working on so
again it's the
stanley street bungalows town center
sherwood road estate
and the norwood road industrial state
again it's looking at how that space is
used and if there's any waves for
inefficiencies or it can be used in a
more cost effective way and maybe
release some
area for development out of residential
commercial
again very much in as as we were with
beckington because we've taken
some kilometre reports together forward
at the same time so again
it'll be after the county council
elections that final report will be
signed off
and so what we're hoping that
we can then bring forward vectors and
kilo march outputs is 50 new homes
a capital receipt of a million pound
reduced costs of a quarter
million and create 75 new jobs
and for clay cross 71 residential units
2 000 of commercial space and potential
receipts of 570 thousand pound
and the the clay cross one is obviously
progressing quite quickly because we
have the town investment plan
and that will be the main vehicle for
driving through the and one public
estate work
so that's a whistle stop tour of the one
public essay
and do you want me to stop sharing and
i can answer any questions
please carl sorry about the slogan you
would
how's everybody feel about about that
diana you've got a question
yeah carl i've got a question going back
to the avenue
the proposed new housing you've got
there is
that part of the already the strategic
figures that
are for the site or are they new figures
now they're part of the um
already been accounted for in the area
and having the area strategic framework
so that's
sort of it's for that whole area so it
does cover our development as well as
the
homes england development okay fine
thank you
there's regard carl as regards um
eckington is the provisioning on this
screen i can't see
every detail there for like a play area
a
children's play area in the development
there wasn't
and that's predominantly because around
one public estate what the outputs is
looking for
is jobs or housing so
players don't fit in with that but they
don't produce the jobs on the dogs to
produce housing so it's not something
that would be
including that within that sort of
piece of work all right thank you that's
a naive question now you've said that
thank you
yeah nigel
nigel are you there thanks chair y'all
just you're still melting myself
uh yeah thanks carl uh
i just want to pick my words here but i
don't want to be too political about
this but
it's fair to say that the one public
estate was was the i think you've
alluded to it with the grounding for the
to get the claycross town fund so and i
know there are a lot of work went into
that
to one public estate stuff i want the
brian harrison and yourself
and others have done a lot of work and i
think i think it's also great that
kilimanjaro eckington's been looked at
because if we can get a similar money
for those towns and it would be great
but without being too political and i
don't blame
er people for for jumping on that one
but
it has got a history clay cross it's not
just arrived
at that i think you know where i'm
alluding to
so uh i'll leave it at that
oh and and thanks for all the way from
the officers to
to get that far i think is important
yeah thanks nigel has anybody else got
anything
for carl any comments any
everyone happy with that that
doesn't surprise me really carl because
you know
a lot of this um we i
i don't i can honestly say i don't
understand
and uh we're supposed to bring your
capable hands to a degree
but thank you for your presentation this
morning
can can i just ask one quick question
please question
yeah that was a bit late coming in i
just wondered whether you've got any
plans for mill lane offices
and rick north offices that whole area
there called does that come into it as
well and there's some challenges around
the offices because there's
um there's covenant restrictive
covenants
on the property so there's overages and
also so it makes it really difficult for
us in terms of
um if we were to do wholesale
redevelopment of those
spaces so i mean as i think we can all
recognize that mill lane's probably not
the most efficient use of space with the
courtyard in the middle and that's not
how commercial
properties are developed nowadays but
unfortunately because of these um
restrictions it would cost i think we'd
have to pay something like a million
pounds
to the previous owners if we were to do
that so that makes any redevelopment
unviable and so that's really quite
challenging in terms of what we do with
that so
that almost takes away that option of
well we'll flatten it and redevelop it
for
brand new commercial space which i think
realistically officers would think would
be a
more appropriate use of it and so we're
kind of having to
make the best of what we got because and
as i say there's there's restrictions in
terms of what we can and can't do
which make it viable for redevelopment
okay thanks and also that property deal
was done
prior to my joining the council so
that's not my fault okay
thank you exactly thank you carla
english
thanks for your question john erin right
folks yeah
well thank you carl uh thanks for
presentation um
we haven't got much to ask you really
but it's kind of what's going on this
morning
i've got you you should all have my
email so if you do any questions by all
means
feel free to drop me a line on anything
really and if i can answer i will if not
i'll point to the appropriate officer
brilliant thank you very much
thank you carl yes thank you thank you
bye
right right we can move on to our next
item which is item number five
um draft scrutiny review
uh so i don't know whether you want to
sort of
come in on at this point and sort of
give us a bit of a
bit of a lead or a bit of a direction
yes we'll do check
uh it's just the concluding of uh your
scrutiny review report that obviously
you've done quite a lot of
evidence gathering over the year so this
is the final report i did put it out
um two members um to to see whether they
had any comments to make on it just
you know both um to be quite honest
accuracy you know spelling stuff like
that
but also if there's anything in there uh
that is not quite what you're looking
for
or there's anything that you feel we've
missed that you've heard during the year
that you want to include in that
and the next stage what will happen is
once you uh finalize it today
um it will then be submitted to cabinet
in the near future
for them to consider recommendations if
they accept those recommendations
um the lead officer will then prepare an
action plan
on how they're going to deliver those
recommendations over the next year
that's about it joe it's it's it's very
straightforward it's just about if
members have any
um further comments or anything that
feel that's missed
right just just to ensure that it meets
what what you know what you'd heard and
what you were thinking when you you put
your recommendations together
right thank you thank you so so
the question is for this i know one or
two have replied
um when sue sent out the um
the report has anybody got any any
further comments on it anything they'd
like to add or
take out or
good that's great not good that saves me
any
any further on that one right well i i
could draw a line of that i think then
sue
number six uh monitoring
of o and s recommendations
sue thank you yes chair um
this is really just a a summary of all
the recommendations this committee has
made
and the other scrutiny committees made
and the reason we produce it and
obviously put it in the public forum
at the end of the year so people both
public and members can see that
the recommendations that have been made
the action has been taken on them
and most of them are are complete so
it's just really a matter of information
um on the fact that the recommendations
have been taken forward chair
right thank you thank you there um
forward number seven forward plan of
cooperative decisions
to consider the forward plan of
executive decisions please this note
uh the most up-to-date plan of executive
decisions can be
accessed via the following link all
right um
this is the usual report chair that you
get that just tells you the decisions
that are going to be taken in next four
months within the authority
i think usually if you've already seen
them in
in other formats but it's just to make
sure that we don't miss anything that
you might want to look at in scrutiny
thank you sir uh number eight work
program
so as we're at the end
is there a work program well again chair
this is
to let you know that hopefully you feel
that you've completed your work program
i think you've
you know obviously a chief focus this
year has been on your review report and
of course the pandemic has
made for more difficult year in in some
of the things perhaps you might want to
look at
so it's um really just to
ensure that you're happy if completed
and obviously when we come back next
year
you will start putting together a work
program we do that by asking any members
particularly if you're going to be
sitting on the group
obviously with consultation with the
chair and put in
any items that you'd like to see perhaps
on that work programme for next year
right okay thank you uh
number nine urgent titan
i think that's just a continuation there
don't there isn't anything
there um
i suppose i could use this this moment
just to
sort of thank everybody for getting
involved uh this year
i've only had it at the chairs um
for about a year and i can be perfectly
honest and
you've all been in the council a while i
didn't know what i was doing at the
beginning
and and there's there's an element i
don't really know what i'm doing now but
uh but thank you for joining in with me
it's
i i think i've waffled quite a bit
uh to try and get you involved in in the
conversation but
your involvement has been appreciated so
thank you very much
um everybody anthony you're a politician
don't have to be that honest mate
no the thing is i don't think i am a
politician nigel sometimes
i don't know because
so um michelle i'd just like to say
thank you for being an
excellent chair
not an easy one now it's a funny sort of
committee our family
because really it it's it's supposed to
be non-political as well isn't it it's
supposed to be it's all about us
just looking at what everybody else is
doing and and and making comment on it
um and and and i'm come across anybody
that's been you know politically uh
motivated
so yeah thank you for that and
and if i can say chair as obviously the
clark well the uh
the officer looking after this committee
you know you've done i'm not just
um saying this you have done a lot of
good work over the year and as
we've spoken of before i think when you
start um
on scrutiny it you know it it takes a
while particularly with a huge subject
like growth
and the economy and all this the areas
that you cover just to get all that
background
ground knowledge um obviously some
members will have been
in this before so we'll have built that
up over the previous years but for
people coming on you
it takes a while to get all that
information and you've heard a lot of
information from various officers during
the year
so as i've previously said i think it's
gone well and i'm quite
uh content with the things that you've
covered during the year and achieved and
certainly with your
uh review report which we'll submit to
cabinet i think that's been a worthwhile
piece
of work excellent thank you thank you
for your feedback sue it's
very much appreciated so i think i think
all of us
here uh uh are staying on aren't we next
year
you have plans to say i anything thanks
guys
so we'll help you too yeah great stuff
yeah we'll just go for
one or two new people i think um
so the data next meeting so is monday
the 28th of june
all right you
you're muted some say it's better that
way but
chair um yes it is chair and it will
soon come round
it will yes won't be longer tool will it
and i think all
the restrictions will have been lifted
by them won't they
so we might be will we be in-house then
we might be in-house
i don't know i don't know nobody's told
me any different but uh i i
i know it's nice being doing it on zoom
but there's something slightly better i
think being in the same room
right right i think this hasn't been
made yet whether we're staying on zoom
or
or going in our source 50 50 has anybody
earned anything
i don't know whether a decision has been
whether a decision has been made i mean
for me i'd i'd rather even though it's
inconvenient if you like
but i'd rather be in and come into the
offices personally because
i think well they only pay me for it and
there
and you've got to be switched on when
you're in
jail if the committee are wanting to
have a discussion we can finish the
public meeting and and go into
just an informal chat if you you'd
wanting to talk about
uh next year and things like that i
don't know i don't know
everybody particularly i think it's just
me waffling now
whether anybody wants to chat about it
but no i think
for me i think we could we can pretty
much close the meeting okay
everybody okay with that thanks anthony
thanks everyone see you later
see ya
you